SHORT TWO GAME TRIP FOR CIRELLID
PALAT CHASING IT.
REBOUND,
THERE'S A QUICK SHOT.
ELLIOTT HAS NO O  BUFFALO LINE.
WELLTHAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENE.
>> SHOT TO THE FAR LINE.
MAYBE ONE WOULD MAKE THE  HE
LIGHTNING, 1-0.
NT AGAIN.
OFF TO THE SIDE OF THE N N LEAD.
LIGHTNING HAVE BEEN PUS FAR
BOARDS.
LIGHTNING DOING A
>>> SABRES LEADING 1-0.
WATCH THEN THE BIG
GUYS, TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
>>
KICK IT TO NET.
FOLLOWING UP,NOSTROZA FROM COZE.
HE SQUEAKED IN POINT.
GOOD TIE UP.
BUTCHER IN A FEW.
HERE'S THE SABRES GETS THROUGH..
PLAYS SEE THAT, TRYING TO GET
AST UP.
SERGACHEV.
SHOT BY
RISTOLAINEN.
AND SENT IT TO SKINNER.
NICE JOB.
SPINNING! FIRST GOAL.
HE IS UNDER
WHAT'S YOUR OUTLET.
LOOK AT THE GOAL SCORERS FOR THE
BUFFALO SABRES.
GAVE THEM THE
THROWS IT UP WITH A  IS THERE T
SUPPORT AS WELL.
5:39ER, LIKE TO SEE
GUYS GET REWEWNOW CENTER ICE.
SENDS THE.
ASPLUND ONCE AGAIN PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY.
LOOK ATT